Étienne Chary a composé la musique
originale du film Le livre des solutions
de Michel Gondry un long métrage
présenté à l'occasion de la Quinzaine
des cinéastes du Festival de Cannes on
en découvre tout de suite quelques
images et si tu veux faire avancer
rapide tu tournes le volant à droite
vas-y tiens
et dans l'autre sens si tu tournes à
gauche
retour rapide
et à l'arrière on installe les
producteurs
étant donné que je possédais évidemment
pas toutes les enfin toutes les je
tenais pas les rennes de l'ensemble du
projet c'était de d'apporter une forme
de sincérité au départ on a fixé comme
une sorte de palette d'instruments
assez disons
passe partout mais à partir de là
il s'agissait de faire passer des
émotions malgré tout assez puissantes
d'accuman accord on a décidé avec Michel
que moi je voyais les images le mieux
c'était donc j'étais comme plutôt une
sorte de robinet à musique au total
Étienne Chary a composé la musique
originale de cinq longs-métrages dont
trois réalisés par Michel Gondry une
aventure musicale qui a commencé il y a
plus de 40 ans lorsqu'il s'est noué
d'amitié avec le réalisateur au lycée de
Sèvres pendant très longtemps quand on
parlait de musique de film je me sentais
même pas légitime pour en faire parce
que ça me semblait un truc énorme mais
bon comme j'ai plutôt par le biais comme
ça commençait à faire des musiques pour
la télévision pour
des génériques pour des documentaires
différentes choses comme ça enfin et à
un moment donné je filmais en fait
pourquoi pas et puis c'est arrivé comme
ça
et puis il se trouve que que Michel qui
était vraiment un ami de lycée
m'a aussi permis de faire des choses de
cet ordre là en parallèle Étienne Chary
compose également des musiques plus
personnelles il y a 10 ans il a lancé
son label imaginaire catalogue dans
lequel il donne naissance à des artistes
fictifs pour créer son propre monde
musical